well al jazeera's jivara budari joins us
here now
javara let me start by asking you how
are you doing today
i'm trying to be okay they broke my hand
i spent all the night in the hospital my
heart
my back hurt me a lot and i hear
my hand from the cuffs also they hurt so
much because
the soldiers in the car were tightening
it
all the time i have a headache
and my leg i can't walk very well
and my voice as you see it was
horrible because not only because i'm
palestinian i'm a journalist
i'm covering like all the journalists
here we're covering
the reality on the ground we are going
we are
just telling the whole world what's
going on here
um until now i'm
under shock uh because i didn't see any
photos from what happened yesterday
because
i was shocked when they began to kick me
and
i was just saying you know i just want
to hear hear
something very important yesterday
especially yesterday i made four lies
for al jazeera and i was walking through
the these
soldiers the same soldiers more than 25
and i made walk and talk story
with my name and the name of the
jazeera i was wearing my vests my press
vest
and i was i am going out and
coming inside
for more than 20 times so they know me
they know who i am and
what the thing that they know
after they they hit me in a very bad way
in the car they were kick they kicked me
a lot
more than outside one of the soldiers he
said that
we arrested the reporter of the al
jazeera
if you don't know if you didn't have my
id how did you know now
after after all the this
criminal show how did you know i am i am
jivara and i am
the reporter of al jazeera and inside
the police station
it was and it was showing that
it's because of al jazeera
one of the soldiers told me we will let
you shut up
you all of al jazeera here on the ground
so all the journalists will shut up if
we
let the al jazeera
be silent everyone will will shut up
one of the soldiers um they were
treating me like a criminal
they refused to take off the cuffs
and as i told you we are journalists
just telling
what's going on on the ground i'm
covering i'm with al jazeera from
21 years old one of the soldiers came
and told me from how long you are in al
jazeera i told him how old are you
he said 20 years i told him i am with al
jazeera before you were born
so we know our work we don't lie
we don't say anything wrong because they
said that al jazeera are saying
everything
they lie a lot i told them no we don't
lie just give me one incident that we
light
what i'm seeing now on the ground after
all these years
this time after all these years this is
the first time we see
this uh unbelievable uh treating towards
jonas and especially towards al jazeera
after covering all what happened in
babylon
in al-aqsa mosque in gaza especially
but um they want the camera
to be broken as they broke it yesterday
with my
colleague nabil mazzawi they wanted the
microphone to be
on the ground but we are telling them
that the microphone and the camera
will stay and we will continue nothing
will stop us nothing we face
more than this and we will continue
javara i'm so sorry that you've been
through that trauma i see your cast
there can i ask how did that actually
happen to your hand
your fracture the broken part of your
hand
the blocking hand from the kicking and
because i was
kicked from everywhere i didn't know
that even i didn't know that my hand is
broken
only in the hospital they discovered
that it's broken
here it's from the cuffs because they
were tightening it
because i was shouting i couldn't
breathe i just told them
please open the the window they wash
every time i'm saying open the window
they were
kicking me with legs and then tightening
the cuffs
it was it hurts a lot but
as i told you it's it's nothing
maybe it's the first time i know what's
the meaning
of being a prisoner i have many friends
and
we covered any many many people who were
arrested
so it's a new a new um
thing to know how to be honest others
are treated sure
how the people of jerusalem are treated
they are treated
very badly inside the police station i
saw
you know small kids they were treated
like criminals they didn't do anything
and even i want to ask them what's going
on
they refused to let me er speak with
them you know
something so so silly i was so tired so
i
wanted to close my my eyes he began to
kick me with
his leg the soldier inside the police
station don't
close your eyes you know why you are
doing like this
if we if we don't cover with camera
there is an iphone
there are a new generation covering
everything
so don't let a new generation coming
to cover what we are covering also uh
javara you've been reporting
for my voice it's absolutely fine uh
javari you've been reporting
as you say from sheikh jarrah for some
time now i'm curious
what has it been like reporting from the
ground there not just for you but for
other journalists how are other
journalists being treated at the moment
you know i can yanni yeah
i i don't remember i can't say that
you know no one was treated in a good
way
all the journalists reporters
cameramen uh sound men uh
um the people who help us even
even israeli journalists
from the uh left side they were kicked
so they know
that this will be any
they want everybody to to be shut up
everybody
all the journalists were treated in a
bad way in babylon
in al-aqsa in in
and we and of course what happened with
our office in gaza
uh this is a a crime so the uh
and all the journalists or anybody it
was
just filming with the with the iphone
they were also kicked
uh we for me for example before two days
i
was kicked in silhouent from four
soldiers
uh with uh with six on my back uh
and uh before that we were kicked many
times from the horses in
babyl amud even the people may say in
the world
it's nothing no it's something because
it hurts
um they want us you know we are feeling
so
you know they thought that we will be
tired and we will stop
and we will not continue no we are going
to continue
yeah if this camera didn't show that
camera will show
and everybody will will speak about that
and the most important thing that now
yani everybody other thing what how can
we help
the journalists of jerusalem because no
one can help them
because they are under the israeli
occupation
it's something so bad towards the the
journalists in jerusalem
it's so so bad the situation there so
we hope something now will change not
because you are albuderi for sure no
i am one of these great people
these journalists who are working some
of them
from 30 years on the ground i'm one of
them
uh but now i think everybody saw
how israel don't want anyone
in the world see what's going on on the
ground no they don't want to see
they don't want to show anybody but from
everywhere
the the the photos are go again going
to everywhere and we are saying about
this generation it's tick-tock
generation this generation who changed
everything
you've said i know that you will go to
court i'm curious
what your next steps will be and also
just around the
the press credentials i know there have
been difficulties in obtaining those
do you think that taking steps to go to
court will make it easier for other
journalists to operate there as well
first of all as al jazeera we are going
to the court
because they said that i beated a
soldier a female soldier they gave me in
the investigation a video about
six seconds and just my hand is like
this
i told the investigator six seconds
and the lawyer told me there is 22
minutes
of video from from all the videos that
shows
the the oppo that show the opposite so
don't tell me about six seconds
so they said the investigator told me
now you have a criminal file
and you have to go maybe you have to go
to the court
so al jazeera will go to the court
because all
of what happened with all the teams
before
two days they broke
our car in silhouene also in beta
they throw gas on the
on the car our cameramen
they were beated very well in very badly
in
other places so al jazeera will go to
the court
and also today all the jurors
said that there is a big file for all
the things that happened towards the
journalists
they are going even to the
international law to the international
criminal
court uh with a big file with all the
things
that shows how israel and the
and the occupation are doing with this
with the
soul with the journalists especially
from
the beginning of ramadan because from
the first day of ramadan
everybody we were covering from babel
they were kicking people and we are just
filming
they were kicking us also why you are
kicking us
and we are just filming we didn't do
anything we have just
microphone we have just camera and we
have our pen that
is that all what we have so
uh now for sure religious zero now we'll
go to the court
and from what i have seen even uh
from some israeli channels they are
in a shock they found our
our boss they said that
it's not a it's not acceptable what
happened yesterday
and uh some leaders told me yesterday
that
um it's it's something the same like
what happened in gaza all this
demonstration demonstration and all the
bad things that happened in gaza
the same like what your photo yesterday
because
you were covering you you didn't do
anything and really
we were covering and we they saw us they
know us
they wanted to let us shut up that's all
jivara budari there al jazeera's
correspondent
speaking to us now from ramallah we wish
you all the best
javara and we're very glad to see you
back reunited with your little girls
thank you thank you so much